so now that we're done our first year of homeschooling
I wanna talk about things that work for us
and things that we're gonna change for next year
the biggest change is that we're gonna be doing a co op next year
a co op means that you can do in person with other teachers
learning with the same group of kids every week
our kids will be going two days a week
and then the rest of the week will be home doing traditional homeschool with mom
and that will come with its own curriculum
which means I don't have to search and find the curriculums I wanna use
even though I liked that part
so I'm a little hesitant to see how this goes
one thing I loved was outsourcing
we found great lessons and extracurriculars
that were working with homeschool students
that really made it just such a fun year for my kids
my biggest struggle was time management
I found our days were actually so busy that by the end of the day
I like if I hadn't figured out dinner already
we were kind of flying by the seat of our pants
so I plan to implement using companies like Hellofresh in the coming year
honestly keeping up with social media was really difficult too
and I don't know if that's gonna be easier next year because the co op
but it may be something I have to re evaluate
I have more to tell you so part two